hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well part three of Emmanuel con
prominant to any future metaphysics is
entitled how is metaphysics in general
possible and K is going to begin by
making some very important distinctions
between metaphysics and the two previous
disciplines that we've looked at in part
one and part two of the work namely pure
mathematics and pure Natural Science and
he's going to say that this is the very
beginning pure mathematics and pure
Natural Science had no need for such a
deduction for the sake of Their Own
safety and certainty we know that they
actually exist and they work and we can
do them so he says uh pure mathematics
rests upon its own evidence that's part
of what makes mathematics so nice we
know we do mathematics we know that we
can do pure mathematics and so you know
this is coming from the categories of
the understanding the pure concepts of
the understanding and also the
engagement with uh pure intuitions of
time and space right and then he says
that the latter that's uh pure Natural
Science though sprung from Pure sources
of the understanding is based upon
experience and its thorough confirmation
so pure natural science cannot refuse
and dispense with the testimony of
experience so with all of its certainty
it can never rival mathematics that's
okay right what about
metaphysics KH has said earlier in the
work that you know strictly speaking
nobody's ever really done a metaphysics
as such they have a term that they use
but the real metaphysics is something
yet to be we could say developed and so
he says that um both of these Sciences
can never as uh you know uh stood in
need of this inquiry not for themselves
but for the sake of Another Science
namely metaphysics we're kind of getting
ready or you might say rehearsing
in looking at pure mathematics and pure
Natural Science for the more difficult
work of figuring out how can we actually
understand and do metaphysics so he says
okay so what does metaphysics do what do
its subject matter says it has to do not
only with concepts of nature which find
their application and experience but
with pure rational Concepts so rational
Concepts Concepts coming from The
Faculty of reason so there's you might
say two parts to metaphysics a part of
metaphysics that has some connection to
experience and then pure metaphysics
dealing with pure concepts of reason and
he says these can never be given in any
possible experience whatsoever so what
does this mean the objective reality of
these Concepts and the truth or falsity
of metaph physical assertions cannot be
discovered or confirmed by any
experience and that's not necessarily
damning if we're leaving out other
things that Kant has said up to this
point maybe there's you know the
empirical side of metaphysics and then
there's the purely rational side of
metaphysics can't be confirmed or denied
by experience okay but then we transcend
and we enter the realm of pure IR
rationality or something like that now
that's going to be an issue as we're
going to see and this is an issue we
cannot avoid why not because Kant tells
us that this part of metaphysics is
precisely what constitutes what he calls
its essential end its zc its goal its
purpose the whole point of metaphysics
is is to do this stuff with what goes
beyond and cannot be confirmed or denied
by
experience so he says that um the rest
of it is only a means and so this
science is in need of a deduction for
its own sake so the third question now
proposed relates therefore he says as it
were to the root the origin right and
then notice this term the peculiarity
the what it is that is really
distinctive you might even say the
specificity or the property of
metaphysics what is unique to it and
what is that the occupation of Reason
merely with itself and the supposed
knowledge of objects arising immediately
from this brooding over its own concept
without requiring experience which is
one thing or indeed being able to reach
that knowledge through true experience
and so we could think about you know all
sorts of previous
metaphysicians all the way up to Kant
Plato is a prime example of this you
know we have this intelligible World
which you cannot see here it's not
Material it's not sensible it's not
within experience but we can have some
sort of
intellectual experience of it through
contemplation and then we can grasp the
world of the forms that would be one
example of what Kant is talking about
here and he says that if we can't solve
this problem reason is never really
going to be
satisfied and here we see something
really interesting being raised at this
point in the work something that is
quite distinctive to to Kant but also to
other thinkers as well he says that the
empirical use to which reason limits the
pure understanding so the stuff we've
been doing up Until Now does not fully
satisfy what he calls reason's own
destination and the word that's being
translated here is destination
Bish this is something that haiger will
make much of later on right uh
destination could work for that um but
also what it is that it's it's most
Desiring what it is that will harmonize
or resonate
with it now what is it he says every
single experience that we have is only a
part of the whole sphere of its domain
but the absolute
totality of all possible experience is
not itself experience and notice what
he's saying you know absoluta so the
absolute totality G right in this case
the the whole the entirety and notice
that he's not using another term that
has been translated as totality earlier
in the work in uh you know in right so
um it's it's the whole and we can think
of the whole we can desire the whole we
can drive after the whole but we can
never reach the whole in
experience it's not something we could
experience just think about like the the
universe itself Kant is going to talk a
little bit later about the cosmological
ideas we can think of the universe right
and we can ask ourselves questions like
does it have an end or is it
Limitless how in the hell would you ever
know that you can't go out to the
boundary of the universe right and even
if you did right you could only go to
one tiny bit of it if we imagine that
sort of thing you wouldn't get the rest
of the possible limits you you can
conceptualize but you can never
experience the totality so he says this
is a necessary problem for reason human
reason extends itself to these
totalities um and he says the mere
representation of which requires
Concepts quite different from Pure
concepts of the understanding where the
concepts of Reason aim he says at the
complete
the full stending kite being brought to
their perfection their fruition or the
collective Unity the collectiva inite
unity being uh something that we we
strive after right um of all possible
experience and thereby they go beyond
any given experience and this is how
they become as he says Transcendent so
you know again so far so good
if we took it just up to this point we'd
have a nice explanation all right
metaphysics takes us beyond what we
possibly could experience to something
greater and you know it transcends the
experiential realm well we got to be
careful here Kant is going to say so we
got to think about the difference
between understanding and its objects
and and reason so he tells us that the
understanding needs the categories that
it has or concepts for experience um and
he says you know this is the way the
understanding the uh you know fan works
what about reason reason contains in
itself the ground for or of ideas and he
says what are ideas necessary Concepts
whose object cannot be given in any
experience now Kant is going to say
something here that might be a bit
controversial the latter namely these
ideas are inherent in the nature of
reason as the former are in that of the
understanding so that is something quite
important if we use reason to look at
itself look of course being a metaphor
here to scrutinize itself we will find
these ideas that we can't help running
into and thinking of and not only will
we find in ourselves these ideas we'll
find them in everybody else similar to
how you know everybody's got the same
categories of the understanding really
big difference here though as he
says concepts of the understanding can
be given we can we can run into them in
experience and they can be confirmed by
experience ideas of reason or concepts
of reason they cannot be given nor can
they be confirmed or refuted by
experience and we'll see this a little
bit later when we get to the antinomies
right so he he tells us that
um this leads to some some issues some
problems he's going to talk about errors
he's going to talk about dialectic he's
going to talk about illusion so the
first reference to illusion we've seen
this brought up you know quite a bit in
earlier sections Illusions he says
illusion consists in holding the
subjective ground of our judgments to be
objective we make a mistake in thinking
that because I judge things to be this
way maybe Express them in propositions
maybe think that I have uh knowledge or
cognition of that or Kess right that
because I get things this way everybody
else does every everybody else is
compelled by the Notions that I'm
working with so you know if that's the
case he says the only safeguard that we
have for Pure reason in its Transcendent
use going Beyond experience is um going
to be you know looking at reason itself
using reason and we want to avoid is he
calls it the aberration into which
reason Falls when it mistakes its def
its destination and transcendently
refers to the object in
itself the numina right which we can't
actually get access to so Kant is going
to say and he's using a metaphor here
that a lot of people doing previous
metaphysics were building Castles in the
Air without knowing the fitness of the
material and these architectural
metaphors are quite common in modern
philosophy are they not you see them in
decart we see them in Hobs we see see
them in all sorts of
people well what material are we working
with
ideas right and so we can't use them to
build the same sort of thing as we would
the concepts of the understanding and
this is what he says the critique of
pure reason is doing for us um and
without this metaphysics is absolutely
impossible or it's a random bungling
attempt to build these sorts of castles
so what sort of mistakes do we have to
avoid what sort of mistakes are we
likely to fall into uh he talks
about you know the erors of pure reason
being discovered only by reason itself
and this is going to lead us into what
he calls
dialectical use or reason itself
becoming dialectical by means of its
ideas and he calls this an unavoidable
illusion which cannot be limited by any
objective and dogmatic inquiries into
things but only by a subjective
investigation of Reason itself as a
source of ideas and this is where he
says in the critique of pure reason in
order to avoid this I made a very uh you
know rigid distinction
between several kinds of cognition and
the concepts belonging to each one doing
that deriving them from their common
source why so that by knowing where
they're originated I might determine
their use with safety and have the
invaluable advantage of knowing the
completeness of my enumeration
classification and specifications of
Concepts a priori and of knowing it
according to principles so doing
metaphysics in a systematic way
requires a Critical examination of the
Transcendent ideas stemming from Pure
reason itself without if we don't do
that we're going to get into all sorts
of trouble so metaphysics has to from
the very beginning if it's going to be
an
effective discipline body of knowledge a
science if you will it's going to have
to be both Transcendent but also so
critical at the same time and Kant takes
himself as being the first person to
actually do this and offer it to his
readers